today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
so we made it we finally made it to the
end of the republican national
convention
i was talking yesterday on the bonus
show with pat and just with people in my
personal life that
i can remember no political event like
the 2020 republican national convention
which so exhausted me from politics
in general because it was so disgusting
and so depraved
so lie riddled that it's an
impossibility to even
keep up with the amount of dishonesty
and lies
and yesterday it was all capped off by
donald trump's speech officially
accepting the nomination he did it at
the white house
uh with 1500 people in an audience no
masks barely a mask no testing
in the middle of a pandemic completely
irresponsible in every way
the imagery included sirens
in the entire background as a soundtrack
to the speech because of massive
protests that broke out
outside of the white house and as you
can see if you look at the picture
of this crowd at the white house it
doesn't look like the type of speech
that would be given accepting a
nomination during a pandemic
questions about whether it's even legal
to do this at the white house using the
white house as a political
prop and of course the um prudence
of using the uh such or having such a
large crowd during a pandemic
certainly questionable at best now the
entire thing
was a fascistic nightmare with donald
trump continuing to paint
uh the left as socialist marxist
agitators if you've taken a look at joe
biden's policy platform or the last
30 years of joe biden's public policy
positions
there is uh really nothing that could be
described as
socialistic or marxist in any way
but this is the way that they are
framing it trump going on for 70 minutes
starting to have sort of the feeling of
these never-ending fidel castro speeches
those would go on for hours this only
felt like ours
and donald trump's orange face starting
to melt during the event and i said
yesterday
you know melania's accent is really
beneath us donald trump's physical
appearance
is part of his narcissistic delusional
complex i think it is very much on this
side of the line and it's part of what
trump imagines
as the idea of trump that people want
the idea that people need to see him in
this particular
way this bizarre shade of orange i don't
know if we call it ochre what we call it
uh this 70-minute droning speech and
what's interesting as we get into the
clips is you might realize that he's
speaking so slowly that even though the
speech was long time wise
it's very low on actual content because
the words per minute are extremely low
it is the type of speech
that you would do if you have these uh
sort of authoritarian tendencies
of wanting the crowd to see you as this
great savior
but yet not really having very much to
say uh let's start donald trump
actually sort of rubbing the noses of
the audience
into the fact that he's using the white
house as a political prop take a look
this november we must turn the page
forever on this failed
political class the fact is i'm here
what's the name of that building
but i'll say it differently the fact is
we're here
and they're not
so as i mentioned before uh are arguably
against the law to use the white house
for a political speech like this there
aren't going to be repercussions
i don't even know how much time we
should spend uh wasting uh
we should waste on that because it will
be a waste the opportunity is removing
trump in november he's not going to have
any consequences for using the white
house in this way then donald trump
really just not making sense throughout
the 70 minute speech
uh becoming even more and more orange
his face looking like it was sort of
melting kind of like the joker in the
the 1989 batman film um and
making less and less sense in terms of
his speech here is trump saying that he
has pioneered the fatality rate on the
virus
thanks to advances we have pioneered the
fatality rate and you look at it and you
look at the numbers
really unclear what that means and then
also really unclear but far
scarier trump talking about putting
so-called patriotic education back in
schools
as i drop my sharpie take a listen take
a listen to this already under
construction we will fully restore
patriotic education to our schools and
always protect
we will always always protect free
speech on college campuses
so that actually made the crowd
momentarily seem alive
in the middle of these endless monotones
but that's really scary
patriotic education back in schools if
you've got a republican telling you
they're going to make education
patriotic
you're right to be scared and concerned
trump continuing this very strange
monotonous delivery here is another
section of it
it's not clear trump believes what he's
saying it's not clear trump even
understands what he's saying
but he is saying it in this strange
monotone
and sparked a new age of scientific
discovery
we set the trends in art and music radio
and film
sport and literature and we did it all
with style and confidence and flair
because that is who we are
whenever our way of life was threatened
our heroes
answered the call from yorktown
to gettysburg from normandy to
iwo jima i mean the delivery couldn't
possibly be less inspiring so in
addition to the duration which was far
too long
reminding me of fidel castro the
complete lack
of energy in terms of communicating
belief also reminding me of of just
other authoritarians who just drone on
and on
and on at one point aaron rupar pointed
out on twitter
the delivery almost sounds like
gregory chanting it's a very unusual way
to deliver a speech take a look
and america against all threats and
protect america
against all dangers we will lead america
into new frontiers of ambition and when
someone speaks in this way
there's no way to discern a narrative
there's no way to sort of craft an
arc and in fact when the cameras would
pan to the crowd
people were on their phones people were
talking to each other a couple of people
looked like they were sleeping because
this is not how you deliver a speech and
tell a story
whether it's a good story or not whether
it's an honest story or not that's a
different
this is just not how you engage a crowd
then
again donald trump citing veterans
choice
as an accomplishment remember veterans
choice was signed into law by barack
obama in 2014.
we also passed va accountability and va
choice our great veterans we're taking
care of our veterans
this actually is something many speakers
have been doing
ivanka trump who introduced the
president yesterday
also touted veterans choices and
accomplishment despite it being
something
barack obama did and then as the evening
wore
on not only did donald trump's face
continue to melt not only was he more
and more visibly sweaty gripping the
podium almost like he needed to in order
to stay upright
he became increasingly unable to speak
tried to say we are going to end our
reliance
instead set our resilience and then
abandon the entire sentence
i change and we will end our resilience
for bad things we will go right after
china
we will not rely on them one bit donald
trump
still unable to say kasim solimani's
name
and the context of bringing up solamani
is actually interesting because a number
of speakers did this
within seconds of each other other
speakers
and donald trump throughout the week
bragged about how donald trump
kept us out of and got us out of wars
and bragged about bombing iran at the
same time
it's orwellian double speak you like one
thing you focus on that that doesn't
sound so good
well trump said the opposite 30 seconds
later you can focus on that instead it's
a sort of something for everybody type
of approach
uh donald trump misreading proudly as
profoundly
my fellow americans tonight with a heart
full of gratitude and boundless optimism
i profoundly accept this nomination
for president of the united states
and then by this point donald trump
simply sleepwalking and sleep talking
finally done 70 plus minutes in
his face has completely melted and this
is
the wrap-up and what you'll notice is
it's been monotone for so long
you you couldn't tell until the last
second that it was finally the wrap-up
there were multiple moments where
it seemed like maybe the rap was
starting but just droning on and on and
on
people on their phones people sleeping
people maybe passing coronavirus back
and forth
this was the the final wrap-up after 70
minutes of sleep talking
and on november 3rd
we will make america safer
we will make america stronger we will
make america
prouder and we will make america greater
than ever before
i am very very proud to be
the nominee of the republican party
i love you all god bless you and god
bless america thank you very much
so a bunch of different thoughts here
first of all
this was really fascistic and
authoritarian in a lot of different ways
the way that he is couching the
opposition is something which of course
they are not
socialist marxists um donald trump
continually not making sense making the
case that
the united states is really chaotic
right now there's crime everywhere it's
crazy
so you should re-elect trump well
trump's president right now
and of course the argument would be well
the chaos is in democrat-run cities i'm
going to deal with that later on in
today's program
and if you elect trump he will stop the
chaos well he's been president for four
years
and he hasn't stopped it at least as far
as he's concerned
so that narrative makes no sense
simultaneously the narrative of
berating china and democrats and who
knows who else
for the virus but doing it at an event
with
1500 people sitting six inches away from
each other with no masks
not having been tested for coronavirus
that's also
completely illogical uh and then tom
nichols had a very interesting
commentary on the broader optics of the
speech nichols tweeted something like
this is his same rally speech that trump
gave
but with a dramatic background the
visual component
of the white house and tom nichols said
this is why you're not supposed to use
the white house as a political prop
because
in a different venue this is much more
obviously
trump's same rally stump speech ranting
but with the background of the white
house it lends it more credibility than
it deserves and it's exactly why you
shouldn't be giving speeches like this
at the white house i thought that was a
very good point
last thing the insistence on marxists
and socialists that the entire
convention but in particular trump
yesterday claimed to be running against
and claim
represent joe biden's views if you know
anything about joe biden you know joe
biden is no marxist or even close to it
but what that is increasingly code for
is
that the platform of joe biden and the
democratic party right now
is one that recognizes that working
people
who live paycheck to paycheck are
disgusted with the murderous failure of
this administration on coronavirus
because that's what it's been
and are responsible the trump
administration
for the dramatically worse than it
needed to be economic situation
as a result so when they talk about
marxists and socialists
those are fear-mongering terms to take
attention away from the fact that this
administration has failed the very
population that they claimed
were going to be doing great which is
just average working-class people
inequality up chaos from the standpoint
of
reacting to protests over police
brutality
an embarrassing laughing stock of a
coronavirus response where countries
have stopped laughing at us now they
pity us now they're scared
and donald trump wrapping it all
together fear-mongering about marxists
and socialists while using the white
house as a political prop
to make people sit there for more than
70 minutes of his monotone
droning in one of the most authoritarian
ways that we've seen him do it
this is really scary stuff and
unfortunately if you've been watching
this week you know
it could work to get him re-elected
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at deepakman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into
text or audio that you can consume in 15
minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for if
there's a full book you're thinking
about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are bruce
murphy and eric
ernst bruce and eric thank you for your
support also a big thank you to barbara
bales who is today's long time
sustaining member of the day
barbara has been a member uh close to
five years an incredible amount of time
join these great people by grabbing a
membership at joinedpakman.com
okay let's go to the phones at
617-830-4750 see what's on people's
minds
let's go first to our caller from the
917
area code who we last spoke to in uh
oh it's been a year actually 917. what's
going on
hi david hi um i'm calling about
um the genocide that's going on in
xinjiang china against the turkic
peoples including the uyghurs
yes um there's a there's a bill that's
been like in committee since march
um called i think the uyghur forced
labor prevention act
um which i believe which would
which would cause corporations that have
factories in xinjiang
to prove that their supply chains don't
include uh slave labor from uyghurs
rather than
in other words they would it put the
burden on them um and i just sort of
wanted to make kind of a shout out for
that legislation there's been very
little
pressure that i've seen put on people to
to make progress on that
um and i just think that's really
crucial um
because right now sort of like we are
all probably walking around
uh in clothing in face masks
and all kinds of things that are made by
these you know a million people detained
and that sort of like a very pressing
human rights issue yeah i think that one
of the things that is an interesting
aspect of this
that maybe isn't being discussed is when
we talk about american relations
with china one of the realities we have
to face
is that the worse our relationship is
with china
the less leverage we have to get them
to change their behavior or to make
demands or whatever
and so you know a lot of the discussion
about trump and china is about
were the tariffs a good or bad idea or
is the relationship between china and
russia that builds
when the us is increasingly on the outs
in that group of three countries
beneficial or not
but there's this other reality that if
trump cared to do something about what's
going on there
we have a lot less leverage when our
relationship is bad
and and when we cut ties and that's sort
of like an
ancillary intangible that we have to
understand is affected by the
relationship the oval office has with
china
can i sort of put another way put
another way of looking at that
yes it's not an argument this is sort of
a reframing is like one of the things i
think about is
when we look back you know 10 years from
now
we're saying in the trump era the u.s
had a very bad relationship with china
and people are going to ask well oh that
makes sense because china was a
totalitarian state
that was putting a million people in
concentration camps and doing medical
experimentation and testing vaccines on
people
obviously you'd have a bad relationship
with china and the answer is
well no actually that really wasn't the
issue at all actually we just had a
problem with
you know they were selling soybeans kind
of cheap and i don't want to understand
reports of that right yeah but now now
of course
it's more than uh it's more than sort of
the way it was in the 50s
yes and of course it's more complicated
than just even
even the soybean explanation but you're
right that when we look back at it it
may be misremembered but
listen this is one of the rel the the
the additional reasons why
having actual diplomats or people who
defer to diplomats
still matters in 2020
and having people who prioritize human
rights i mean care
i mean and i would point just in one
second the the biden campaign put out a
very good statement the other day
there the trump administration is
apparently considering
labeling this a genocide which i think
would be an enormous step
hopefully they do that the biden
campaign put out a good statement saying
i believe saying we will do that if we
come into office
but i think that's something that we
should be putting a lot of pressure uh
on institutions to do right now is to
really make some kind of impact on that
issue
all right not a not an unreasonable idea
i appreciate the phone call
thank you david all right take care
let's go next to our caller from the 319
area code who's calling today from 319.
hey david um i'm going to call myself
tim
um and i'm part of the yang gang here
and i'm curious to see what your opinion
is on this um
i'm actually uh a little different from
the yang gang um
because i think that actually looking at
the different candidates that
uh mr yang is supporting across the
board including
um and i'll encourage everybody to look
these guys up um alex morse an amazing
candidate
and also dr robbie goldstein and another
amazing candidate
um there in massachusetts and so um i'm
seeing um
he's being even to my opinion being more
effective
being outside of kind of being in this
um
uh outside political role instead of
being on the inside and so
because of that i'm actually starting to
think as like
a very proud card-carrying member of the
yan gang
um that he actually might not be as
effective in a presidential role
and instead it might be more effective
in a sort of like
semi-political role and so i want to see
what your take on that
is um considering that you know um you
look at donna hyman
in uh texas uh this 31 she's an amazing
candidate
um who won her primary there and i would
love to see her go on and win so i don't
see what your take is on that
i think it's completely reason i mean so
okay here's the thing about andrew yang
one of the critiques of andrew yang
during the campaign i mean again
remember he never pulled more than like
two percent so we're talking about
things in a sort of abstract sense but
one of the critiques of andrew yang
during the campaign
was that maybe he had too much of a sort
of consultancy
approach to politics where everything is
you know it's just like project
management and it's sort of like
the tainted or influenced by
his entrepreneurial background there
were some people who were critical of
him along those lines
the reality is that that works really
well in what you're talking about which
is
he has a sort of fixed amount of
political capital right now
and you can be strategic about saying
okay
he's going to get behind alex morris by
the way alex morris was on on
my show last week and this other person
he could influence people in this way i
think that
andrew yang's strengths work
very naturally in building coalition
and uh supporting other candidates
mobilizing people doing interviews and
getting people aware of some of these
candidates so i think what you're saying
makes a lot of sense
yeah and so um i guess i'm just coming
in from the standpoint of
um personally i guess i see
his support for a four-day work week
being a much more
palatable policy and if i think that he
actually might be more effective and
pushing say
um you know uh biden or if not biden
then
um some of the other candidates for um
whoever comes after biden
on say a four-day work week which i
think would um you know i think uh
that's where i stand in the way if the
four day work week just um
needs to be a thing here so anyway
especially
in the coved era where it seems like
everybody's working around the clock
and um yeah so anyway uh thanks for your
input
all right thank you for the call great
to hear from you uh
where are we going to go next so many
people holding it's hard to uh
it's hard to really know let's go to our
caller
from the 707 area code who's calling
today from
707. hey david this is devon
hey devon what's going on hey i'm a
really long time listener i
am in northern california i'm a 34 year
old
single father of a seven-year-old who
i'm homeschooling right now
okay and um i have one question and two
comments
okay my one question is um
you know i'm not a pessimistic kind of
person but what is the worst case
scenario for our election this year
like if trump wins and they take the
house and the senate aren't we in some
real trouble
that is the worst case scenario yeah the
worst so the worst case scenario would
be
a democrats don't take the senate
democrats lose control of the house
trump gets himself reelected he uh
during his next term uh chooses
replacements
for clarence thomas and ruth bader
ginsburg to the supreme court
turns his 300 or however many judge
selections into 600 and ushers in
a wave of trumpism in 2022 and 2024
that it takes 20 years to disabuse
ourselves from
that's the worst case and it's pretty
bad
you know not only that but if all that
happens
i just see us as like an american people
like we're gonna fall so short to the
view of the entire world
of course like it's yeah i know and i
just i don't know how to really put it
but
you know um having being the age i'm in
i was in
a sophomore in high school when 9 11
happened and it was a pretty
impactful thing on my life but this
presidency
has really shown how far you know we've
fallen even since those times
yeah and it's just really sad it's sad
and you know the the the us
has become a laughingstock and the pity
of the world
so we are a laughingstock but it's
actually
gotten so bad that in some places they
now they're not laughing anymore
they pity us and unfortunately you have
a lot of the 60-something million people
who voted for trump
who see that as a badge of honor they're
emboldened by the fact that people in
other countries think we're out of our
minds they think that means we must be
doing something right
so i'm a distiller from northern
california we make vodka and whiskey and
stuff and i've always had to deal with
the federal government
regulations yeah and i've always found
it to actually be a really fair system
if you're willing to deal with it and
hold up your end of the deal at this
point working with the federal
government
it just seems like they are going so far
off the deep end when it comes to steven
neuching
and policies when it comes to
immigration it's just it's almost like
um
i i don't recognize the country i live
in anymore i i'm with you my whole life
yeah and i've always wanted to like you
know save up money and go vacationing
and kind of
go around the world and tour the place a
little bit but i don't feel welcome
well yeah i mean right now it's not only
that it's also what's going on with
coronavirus but i understand that and uh
that is a that that that's
a major problem and i've exp i've told
stories about that before
uh and it's so it doesn't feel good it
doesn't feel good yeah go
going into work at four in the morning
for the last 10 years um my local radio
station
kcyx would have your show on i've been
listening to it
and i uh have gone to youtube to watch
you now and i really appreciate
everything you're doing and the way you
disseminate information you're my
favorite
kind of news personality out there and i
just have one more comment
yeah during the debates i wish
joe biden would tell trump we're going
to make america great again
that would be interesting at the bar now
yeah that'd be amazing and i want to get
a blue hat that says
you know what i mean it's just it's such
a weird position to be in but
joe biden actually has the opportunity
to do it and it's just
it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
me just to change things back around and
you know i really appreciate everything
you do and i'm like
so excited i always call in for having
you take my call this is the first time
i just you're awesome man all right
devin from california thank you for the
call
great to hear from you uh let's go next
to our caller from the 978 area code
who's calling today from nine
seven eight hi i'm brett fitzgibbons
i'm sorry did you say your name is brett
brett yes
what's going on brett well
let me tell you something i've i put in
my application to city hall
for a mail on ballot yeah and it was
it was never delivered by the by the uh
post office okay let's back up brett
where so where what part of the country
are you talking about you're here in
boston
um on the north north shore north shore
okay
and did you call and ask what's going on
with your ballot
yeah i did and that's they told me they
mailed them out a week ago
and it was never delivered yeah so i
actually
it took me three weeks to get mine
and um i when i called they said and
this is a quote
it's because of what's going on with the
post office which struck me as very
ominous
so i mean i do think you're now you're
talking about for the september first
primary right
yeah yeah which is just a few days away
i was asking for the mail on ballot for
the presidential
but they don't go over it wait wait a
second hold on let me back up brett are
you are you saying you
you're waiting on the ballot for
november
yeah oh no they haven't sent those out
yet there hasn't there's still a primary
on september 1st it's fine
you shouldn't have gotten the november
ballot yet that's normal nobody's gotten
it yet in massachusetts
i've got no ballot now to me did you
request
the democratic primary ballot because
you do have to request that you should
yeah you did okay so that's the one i'd
be concerned about the november one not
so much
uh it's yeah it's a problem now if you
don't get it by september first will you
go in and vote in person
we've got well we've got early voting
right now oh okay
i have to go down and vote this week
you're gonna do it okay very good well
yeah i mean listen it's a mess i'm
hearing these stories from all over the
country
yeah it's crime yeah
all right my friend brett thank you for
the call uh great to hear from you and
uh yet another
data point um about how bad it is
uh with a lot of this um uh post office
shenanigans that are going on let's take
a quick break if you're holding
don't hang up because i'm going right
back to the phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay let's get right back to the phones
at 617-830-4750 there are
many people who are hoping to
get on the phone let's go to our caller
from the 215 area code who's calling
from two one five today
hi dave did this thing yeah who's this
uh this is ryan i'm actually pulling
from raleigh north carolina
all right and we're not on speakerphone
are we uh no do you need i
i do have my headset and i need to get
out i think it's okay
okay um i just had a quick question
about biden's environmental plan so
as we know he's using the green new deal
as a framework as you said
um and one of the things to my
understanding that he's using is
uh he's including nuclear power into
this
into his uh environmental plan i was
kind of hoping to get your idea
or i guess your thoughts on nuclear
power in general and then
how do you think uh the american people
will think about it
so i like this question because i think
that there is a lot of mis uh
misinformation and mistaken beliefs
about nuclear among some on the left who
are just reflexively against it and and
often the reason that people on the left
are against nuclear power
is because they imagine that new nuclear
with modern technology would have
all of the same risks that existed 40
and 50 years ago with nuclear
which is simply not true so i actually
in principle don't have a problem with
nuclear new nuclear as a bridge
to getting to alternative energy at some
hopefully defined point in the future i
think that
people on the left who just say it's
unsafe don't understand how dramatically
different
modern nuclear would be and the ways the
technologies that would make you know a
so-called meltdown
almost impossible so that's one piece of
it
the problem i have with nuclear is that
it takes a long time to get new nuclear
capacity
online and i question
whether the time it would take to do it
would simply be a disincentive and would
just justify
delaying getting on clean renewables all
together
and so that's my question mark i don't
remember how many years it is
that it takes to put new nuclear online
but
i would like to be significantly in the
direction of clean renewables by then
and i wouldn't want
the project of doing new nuclear to
delay
uh what what eventually should be the
the end goal but i think the people who
are just like oh it's just unsafe we
shouldn't do it
i'm open to the idea of nuclear as a
bridge but i would want to be really
clear about how do we get back off of it
yeah no i totally agree with that i'm
actually going for my doctorate in
nuclear engineering so i'm kind of
biased towards
oh okay well i don't have to tell you
then yeah yeah no that's good i
i just wanted to get your take on it and
see your take on
how the american people would kind of
feel about it because i'm definitely on
board for it just because
of how our electrical system works and
how everything's on demand and
you know wind and solar are nice and
stuff but we don't have the
capabilities to store that energy
economically
so you know nuclear is definitely one of
the options to get um on-demand power
that's
definitely a carbon-free yeah i think we
will have i think we will have the
ability
as the energy storage problem i believe
is going to be solved but you're right
that right now it is
it is a problem that we have not yet
solved
okay thanks so much for your tip my call
david all right thank you
appreciate the phone call uh let's go
next to our caller
from country code 49 country code 49
what's your name
and where are you calling from
hey david my name is corey i'm calling
from well i'm i live in heidelberg
germany but i'm on vacation in methane
germany which is
the northwest corner which is about 10
minutes from the netherlands
right that sounds nice how what's the
situation there from the standpoint of
the virus
i'm actually at a family resort right
now looking at a uh i'm in a sports bar
drinking a beer and i'm looking at
families separated from each other
and uh yeah it's kind of weird because
we decided to take this jump because
we've been stuck in her not really stuck
in our house but
you know we've been playing it safe for
since mid-march since you guys have
yeah and um yeah we decided to just do
it and we're here and we
you know we're doing what we can we wear
masks where we can but you know
germany's doing quite well you know had
five i think six deaths yesterday and
you know that sounds terrible
you know when you say oh i only had five
or six deaths but
you know you know what i'm saying yeah
the u.s had 1300 yesterday so it's a
dramatic difference
yeah right so i
i've been listening to you since the joe
rogan pods we've been with joe rogan a
couple times and i'm a big fan since
then i'm obsessive really
listening to you every day i look at you
as i jog every day and
just i agree with so much of of your
your energy and your soul and where
you're coming from and i'm so happy that
i got a twitter uh notification today
and i'm on vacation i was like
i gotta call in because it's the first
time i've ever found out when to
call so right really what i wanted to
call what i wanted to tell you was that
we're doing good here
i'm actually going to the netherlands
tomorrow to do some shopping
uh come back across the border there's
no restrictions everything's wide open
we're doing fine here i don't feel you
know
i'm super nervous about everything uh in
the united states right now
i work for i worked for as a contractor
employee with um
with nato and and i know i think i
understand your feelings about
um you know the military presence or
police state across the world i think i
have a pretty
good understanding of your take on that
but what what truly got me scared is
um you know obviously that he wins four
more years but
it's i could lose my job over this this
whole thing with
um you know him just being pissed off
with miracles okay i'm gonna take
everybody out because i don't like her
i'm gonna take everybody out of out of
uh germany and put them in
who knows where he wants to put them i
think it's just available right at this
point
but i've never really understood your
feeling about
nato as a whole you've never really
expressed that i've never really heard
you say it i know that you're against
the quote-unquote police state but how
do you feel about
nato in general i don't have any
particular problem
with the idea of organizations
like nato i think the devil is in the
implementation
but i think in in a theoretical
framework
shared defense agreements are reasonable
they make sense we have an increasingly
globalized world you know we often say
um at the country level there are some
problems that are too big for anybody
but government to solve and that's why
libertarian ideas sort of fall short
like there are some things big
regulatory things that you just need the
power of government when you've got a
multi-multi-billion dollar
corporation government is what you need
in order to regulate it
and even beyond that when you have
multinationals
and problems that span across multiple
countries
you need some kind of higher
infrastructure and
something nato like is fine that doesn't
mean i necessarily agree with everything
nato does or every
every one of nato's actions including
you know we could go back to the clinton
era or whatever
but i have no problem with with
frameworks like nato in principle
yeah i think i think i get your your
feeling on that it's
it's just for me it's just such a it's
like a
two or three year old tantrum right now
with him
with trump against miracle and that's
what that's what bothers me the most
it's just so petty and yeah there's
issues with nato for sure but
you know i'm married to a german uh lady
and i've been here for 10 years
since 2005 off and on but a total of 10
years and i just bought a house here and
i'm so disgusted with what's happening
stateside
but i'm pretty much making my life here
at this point i was i was ready to move
back
i had all these plans to moving back in
2016.
and then it just yeah it's just my
mindset
it's completely shifted and that sadly
it shifted we had already planned on
moving back but
um anyways david i'm gonna listen to you
every day i hope to continue
conversation with you you're doing great
things
i've turned you on to a bunch of people
keep doing the great work man
all right corey from germany thank you i
appreciate the uh the kind words and the
phone call from germany
let's go next to our caller from the 317
area code who's calling today from 317
hello david this is melinda
and i just started recently watching
you and thank you so much for last night
helping me get through the
election i just want to put that out
there i would have made it through you
made it
fun listen i barely made it through the
rnc
i didn't hear you say again i was barely
able to make it through the republican
convention
i know uh and the night before i've been
watching i was like i was flipping
through the station trying to figure it
out
but what i want to say is that i'm new
to all of this i never was one to be
into politics up until now you know and
lately it's like i'm losing so much
sleep
with you know i'm just so scared that
we're going to wake up one morning
and we're going to have foreign soldiers
on our soil because it just feels
like he's weakening the
the country it's scary um
it's like um i used to be so proud to be
an american a black american and now
it's you know um i'm getting to the
point where
i had heard a caller ask what is the
worst case scenario i started to hang up
because
it was pretty much my answer worst case
scenario was
what my nightmare has seen it so my
question is
with him doing all of this where he
is constantly breaking the law and
not abiding by the rules and
why don't they and and i'm dummy to this
right now and just learning why can't
they just
all get together and put him out with
even knowing the next four years
with what could come with him being in
office again
why why don't they just clean the white
house
out with all of his people and just
move around why is he even able to even
run
for president again
so linda here this is a great question
so when you say why don't why don't they
just remove him who's the they you're
talking about
the the it's a lot of republicans i'm
sure
they're scared um the democrats it seems
like they're scary
i don't understand why they don't the
politicians just don't get together
and remove him out of there why was he
even allowed to even run again with
everything that's
going on okay so let me explain that
this is a good question because it's
you're you're coming into this and
you're
applying logic to a situation that's not
logical so
uh trump was impeached by democrats in
the house
and then there was a trial in the senate
there's a majority of republicans in the
senate and the
and the republicans decided they weren't
going to convict donald trump so the
reason they didn't do it is because they
don't want to it's political
republicans have decided either it would
be bad for them or it would be bad for
their party or whatever
or they don't think trump did anything
wrong so the
the democrats can't remove him because
you would have to
through impeachment convict in the
senate republicans have a majority
they voted to acquit you could then
remove trump via
the 25th amendment if trump's cabinet
determined that he was
unfit to serve there'd be a special
mechanism under the 25th amendment to
remove him
republicans at trump's cabinet don't
want to do it so
this is how we end up at linda that
in 10 weeks we can remove him if we vote
him out that's the way we do it
okay i'm doing everything i can my
little trump change i tried to
uh donate and um i'm
influencing my family to vote vote we
gotta vote like we've never
voted before yes um i just
encourage everyone that's listening to
just please
vote get get out there tell your family
um because it just and that was another
question if they're
how how does our vote count if they're
saying electoral
vote electoral vote
and i'm from indiana and it's like we're
a red state and i'm like everyone i talk
to
i don't see how we're read it i don't
know how electoral quotes work
i've tried to google it look it up and
see how that worked i understand
the basic of it is that that state has
this many electoral votes
i i kind of understand that part but
if the majority of the people that i see
a lot of people and i know there are a
lot of people that
are for republican diehard republicans i
get it
but at this point it's like let's just
do what's best for the nation period the
country
um i i'm just
really scared and i thank you so much
for your broadcast
and and dumbing it down for people like
me
um to understand um i thank you so much
and i'll try to watch the show tonight
rnc tonight i'll try
um but sometimes it just gets so to the
point where you just want to puke
because
even i see all the bad
stuff that's going on around here it's
like it's crazy
all right linda i appreciate the phone
call thank you so much glad you're
newly politically engaged very important
to be doing so
that's going to do it for calls today as
always
sincere apologies that i was not able to
get to everybody
but we will take calls again that's my
promise to you
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well
read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's jump into audience questions
for the week the first
is hey david how likely is violence
after the november election
so there's a few different aspects to
this question the
you're not clarifying violence against
or
by which group and i think there's a few
different scenarios that could lead to
violence now
the the most likely scenario that leads
to violence
is trump claims it was rigged
and his supporters take to the streets
with guns
that would be the top like red alert
violence possibility
in my mind um are there scenarios
in which so you know there are right
wingers
who seem to be suggesting that if trump
gets reelected
the left is going to become so
out of control furious that the left
will start
rioting and burning things to the ground
and
looting and and and all of this stuff um
i that's not really what i'm afraid of i
think that if donald trump were to get
reelected
there will be it'll sort of be a 50 50
effect
some people much like when trump was
first elected in november of 2016
will be outraged and will take to the
streets and
as you remember from november of 2016
those were widely peaceful protests
november december 26th i don't even
remember
uh incidents um
you know nationwide protests hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of people
protesting and
you know you could probably find some
news story of some anecdote but it was
not part of the narrative very different
than
the narrative that the wright created
around the george floyd protest so some
people
on the left certainly if trump is
reelected they will be out there
protesting
but there's also going to be a lot of
people on the left who are just totally
deflated and i
expect a portion of the left will check
out of politics for
maybe not four years but certainly until
the 2022 midterm
and then we'll get involved in the 2024
election relatively late because it will
be i mean listen i
i understand i've said before um trump
is better for my business
but he's terrible for the country and so
i am fine
with my business not doing as well if
it's good for the country
but if it's another four years of trump
it is go
i'm going to certainly be deflated and i
know there are lots of people on the
left who will be as well and i would not
be shocked for a bunch of those people
to check out
so i don't believe there's a real risk
of violence if trump
wins now if trump loses there's a couple
different scenarios there's trump loses
by an insane margin like electorally
it's a huge margin and popular vote i
don't think that the right is likely
to become too violent in that case trump
could claim
it's obviously rigged because i never
would have lost by this much but i think
the truth is that if both the popular
vote and the electoral vote are big
margins for biden
i think that by and large the trumpists
will just say wow we just lost and they
will
essentially disappear for some period of
time i don't think they're likely to be
violent in that case
i think the two scenarios for violence
would be
big popular vote win but it's
really tight electorally and trump loses
by just like one or two states
and claims it's rigged i think that
scenario could certainly lead to
violence and then i think the one that
is most likely to lead to trumpists out
in the streets
is that everything is close and trump
loses uh both electorally and popular
vote
and says it was rigged and that's the
one where i would worry about you know
the so-called gun
people that donald trump has referred to
um going out there
and doing some uh some some horrible
things
i believe it will be relatively
short-lived
um if and when it becomes clear that
trump just lost and no secretary of
state is going to
save him and that even if he could
file some lawsuit to get a recount or
even flip one state that that it won't
be enough
in the scenario where it's a bigger
victory for joe biden if indeed that
happens
uh i think that the the violence will be
quelled
relatively quickly and by inauguration
time
i believe it will essentially be over
now whether we see
more radical extremists activated
if trump is removed that's a fair
question which i'd have to think about a
little more but
i think that the most likely scenario
for violence is
a trump loss that is not a major loss
that it's close
and trump claims it's rigged maybe
refuses to concede and continues to
argue that either vote by mail went
wrong or something like that that's the
scenario that to me lends itself most
uh to violence in the streets and i hope
that uh authorities
will be ready and prepared to deal with
that
hey david i'm looking at the electoral
map
and it just doesn't seem like trump can
win is it even
possible for trump to get 270 electoral
votes at this point
yes yes yes yes yes do not for a
fraction of a second think that there is
not a path to victory
for donald trump there is a path to
victory for donald trump now i
understand the thought process
if you start with the 2016 map and you
look at
wow trump lost the popular vote by 3
million
and it was really one of the narrowest
scenarios where you could lose
nationally by 3 million and win
electorally and the reason trump won was
because of three states
michigan trump won by like 0.2
it was like 10 000 vote margin in
michigan um
in pennsylvania trump won by under one
point
and in wisconsin trump won by under one
point it was only about 23
000 votes 22 000 something votes in
wisconsin
so when you look at that and you say
well okay
that's how it was in 2016. trump's
losing wisconsin
he's losing michigan he's losing arizona
which he won he's losing florida which
he won
he's only winning by one in georgia he's
only winning by two in texas
north carolina is basically a tie ohio
is basically a tie
iowa's barely in the trump camp right so
when you look at it you just say
biden's gonna flip something biden's
gonna flip something and then
immediately
the map becomes very difficult for
donald trump
do not fall into that line of thinking
it is
very much the case that donald trump has
a small margin of error
he can't afford to lose very much and
still win
and i think it's important to remember
how traumatized
we are by 2016 and
that may make some of us find paths for
trump in order to not get a false sense
of security
you don't need to concoct anything
outrageous what you have to remember
is donald trump is a desperate cornered
animal
we learned earlier this week that don jr
reportedly
fears that if trump loses
they all get prosecuted and indicted so
trump is fighting not only for his
political life here but he's fighting
at least as done as far as don jr thinks
to keep himself
out of court potentially for the next
however many years
he lives quite frankly i don't
necessarily believe that but if you
believe don jr believes it
they are acting out of desperation so
they're going to do post office
they're going to do voter suppression
they're going to allow foreign meddling
which they've never tried to stop
bill after bill after bill over the last
four years mitch mcconnell does nothing
with it
trump never talks about you know okay
you get it um
purging voter rolls they're gonna do all
of it
so i get it you look at the map from
2016 and you go well if
you just flip florida i mean it's
already looking bad for trump if you
just flip wisconsin and pennsylvania
it's bad
i get it do not we don't need to pretend
that trump is winning by a lot right now
we just need to understand
that you could again have joe biden win
maybe
biden wins instead of by 3 million votes
by 4 million votes
but that extra million comes in blue
states
and trump still pulls off an electoral
victory
that's the way we have to be thinking
and um yes
donald trump very much can achieve 270
electoral votes hey david why are the
most dangerous cities run by democrats
so this is a pretty old trope uh and i
maybe we can kind of address this piece
by piece
donald trump and republicans have been
harping on this a lot
uh democrat-run cities are riddled with
violence
so vote for me instead of joe biden even
though of course trump is already
president
and there's still violence in those
cities so here's what there's a few
things you have to understand
most cities are run by democrats period
so
violent cities are run by democrats and
non-violent cities are run by democrats
to use crass terminology additionally
the violence is disproportionately in
urban
areas so when you think about cities
instead of areas you start to get this
talking point that trump has been
repeated so
if you look at mayors 35
of the 50 largest cities are run by
democrats
13 are run by republicans and two are
democratic leaning
independents so because more cities are
run by democrats
you have to account for that in your
analysis
the large republican cities are
san antonio i'm sorry san diego run by
republican mayor san diego
jacksonville jacksonville is more
dangerous than the average in florida
it's run by a republican
fort worth texas run by a republican
it's a it's more dangerous
than the average of texas in terms of
crime rates
el paso texas is safer than average for
texas
oklahoma city run by a republican more
dangerous than average
so what you really just have to
understand is that there is a sort of
base rate bias that you you have to
account for the largest cities
run by democrats are the largest cities
in the country uh
crime tends to uh be greater
in places with large population density
for a number of different reasons that
we understand
cities have more crime because they're
more densely populated cities also vote
more for democrats
because they are more cosmopolitan
higher education rates we know more
educated people tend to vote for
democrats instead of republicans
and that does not directly link to
the crime is because the mayor is a
democrat and this has been widely
debunked
and it doesn't even pass the sniff test
there is not actually any correlation
between crime and democrat democratic
mayors when you account
account for crime being more prevalent
in cities and the fact that democrats
lead
a majority of the cities in the united
states including cities with low
crime rates now when you look at the
south for example
and the south at both the city and state
level
is disproportionately under republican
rule
they have some of the highest poverty
rates in the united states
does that mean that republican rule
causes poverty
maybe it does and that's a better
argument quite frankly
than crime in so-called democrat cities
but you still have to look at details
and understand more to really know what
it is that is going on
now when this conversation comes up we
also
shouldn't ignore a broader context about
crime
that crime has been decreasing for
decades overall
and we might be better served
understanding that
and also looking at areas rather than
just cities what republicans do
is they shift the focus to cities rather
than areas
and that allows them to play on these
bigoted racist ideas that the city is
filled with
these scary minorities who are going to
rob you
and sexually assault you and sort of
like the willy horton ad type of
mentality
what that shifts attention away from
is the reality that republican-dominated
areas
have violent crime that on a per capita
basis
is just as bad as a lot of the cities
cities have more people and have more
population density
so you are going to see more crime in
sort of an absolute sense so when trump
talks about the number of shootings in a
city
those are not per capita numbers and in
order to really assess this you have to
zoom out a little bit
and look at areas rather than just
cities and of course
cities overwhelmingly run by democrats
because
democrats tend to be more interested in
being in cities
it really throws the entire idea in the
trash now one one other thought about
this
even if let me see how to say this the
right way
even if on a per capita basis there was
less violent crime
in republican run areas than
democratically run areas
it ignores the fact that people in the
republican areas
suffer in many other ways as well right
economic deprivation is
disproportionately in the united states
in republican run areas now on a
population on a raw numbers basis they
are less populated areas
but on a per capita basis if you look at
economic deprivation
under investment in government ba
terrible resources
bad infrastructure you know all this
stuff you see it on a per capita basis
disproportionately in republican areas
and that's important to bring into the
conversation as well although it's like
who
i'm talking to you guys the people that
just repeat
violent democrat cities aren't willing
to hear this
so there are those are a few thoughts
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video